it's easy to be pessimistic about many
pains stay to the planet the economy the
future of humanity yeah there's one area
where many of us retain a curious sense
of optimism we have faith that from
among the millions of our fellow human
beings out there we will one day be able
to locate a very special person being
uniquely well suited to our temperaments
tastes and aspirations someone who will
feel like the missing bit of the
complicated jigsaw of our deep selves
someone who can make us whole we know it
won't be easy to find them so many
people seem nice at first and then the
problems emerge it turns out they have a
very annoying sister or they're far too
nervous about things always insisting on
arriving at the airport three hours too
early or they have a boring taste in
music or their conversation after a long
day at work leaves a lot to be desired
that's why we keep searching calling for
more space taking a break getting
divorced scrolling through future
possibilities online and then it seems
that we must be very romantic to put
such effort into finding the right
person in truth our perpetual search is
really a refusal of love it is a
guarantee that we can never succeed at
relationships because in the end the
deep secret to love is that there is no
right person
there are perfect beings we can imagine
them very clearly but tragically they
exist only in the upper atmosphere and
never down here on earth
it's the insistence on people being
right that's at the root of rage and
intolerance for we are never more
furious than when we believed we had
signed up to perfection given what the
human animal is like we can be
guaranteed always to find something that
isn't entirely right to be really
romantic truly committed to what love
requires we need a vital and rarely
mentioned quality a healthy dose of
pessimism pessimism about what even the
most perfect seeming person will really
be like once one gets to know them and
with that pessimism comes forgiveness
for the inevitably very long range of
flaws that will discover in them and
they will of course discover in us an
optimistic search for the perfect person
commits us eventually to throw away
everyone we're ever likely to meet yet
in truth the person who is really best
suited to us is not the person who
shares all our tastes but the person who
negotiates differences in taste
intelligently and wisely compatibility
is an achievement of love it can't be
it's precondition to be able to love
properly we have to attend a funeral
first we have to bury a lot of our hopes
deep in the ground
that funeral is the most romantic thing
we could ever do it will liberate us to
go back out into the world and have
proper human relationships that can
injure and
you